you know hi Peter I haven't heard from  you in a while so I thought I'd give you  a call that's it I love you it's your  mother just goes by in a flash I know  you tell me the same thing every 10  years come here  yes no not a lot I mean sometimes what's  your name Gloria are you asking me out  out out you want more of the sides not a  little bit more than that  [Music]  if you were water I'd be a glass to her  foot I'd be a sock  [Music]  kick it out of my head  happy with you I thought it was never  gonna happen again  happy birthday sweetheart that's my  ex-husband then what's in an easy  situation really I searched for your  eyes I didn't exist  what is this good luck I love away from  the car 1 2 3  Metro Manila thumb bring her right  respect her  it cost me every five minutes don't pick  it up  [Music]  there him yeah oh my god honey he's  gotta die tomorrow we could all die  tomorrow  [Music]  when the world blows up I hope I go down  dancing  [Music]  you